Santiago Buenas noches una situación de
tensa calma en el Perú los resultados
que se han producido en las últimas
horas Pedro Castillo ha sido declarado
destituido por el parlamento de Perú
quién le declaró la vacancia
presidencial fueron ciento un votos a
favor el presidente del parlamento José
Williams invocando el artículo 113 de la
Constitución peruana adelantó este
proceso precisamente hubo diez
abstenciones y seis legisladores se
opusieron a esto ellos precisamente son
los congresistas integrantes del partido
Perú libre Perú Bicentenario y también
del Bosque el bloque magisterial ellos
son incondicionales a Pedro castillo y
por más que haya seis investigaciones
por presunta corrupción en la fiscalía
peruana ellos se manifiestan que se
trataría de una injusticia y que Pedro
Castillo fue removido injustamente del
cargo sin poder este haber hecho el
derecho la defensa pero Se olvidaron que
previamente Pedro Castillo sin ningún
fundamento cerró el congreso y declaró
el toque de queda por eso la las
instituciones de este país como la
contraloría general de Perú están
abriendo acusaciones contra Pedro
Castillo el ex gobernante se encuentra
en estos momentos en la prefectura de
Lima y el Primer Ministro Aníbal Torres
está cumpliendo las labores de abogado